this isn't your average spider first of
all it lives in Africa second of all it
isn't satisfied with just insects this
fishing spider lurks near water and
lives to prey on fish tadpoles or in
this case frogs now you're probably
asking yourself how a spider catches
kills and eats a frog
well fishing spiders rest on the water's
surface with their hind legs anchored on
a leaf or rock when it detects
vibrations of passing prey it pounces
with lightning speed and subdues its
catch under its body the spider releases
digestive enzymes over the Frog that
cause it to liquefy it retreats to a
quiet spot to enjoy its meal
yes this spider will eventually eat this
entire frog